[Music]
let's start with the intro yeah let's
start with the Bongo the whole reason we
have the Bongo here the work he put in
to make this event live is unbelievable
like I'm trying to do an opening here
just give me a little background we
travel everywhere I love to smoke
obviously he'll be here in two seconds I
wanna
yeah I don't think that there's a studio
audience no
that's a laugh track
yes how it sounds with this you have no
idea the work that went into this and
creating something for you to tap into
that how does it sound like there's a
World Cup soccer stadium totally yeah
totally yeah
full potential I'm sure I heard like a
voodoo zayla in there dude
obviously he'll be here in two seconds I
want to end with this you have no idea
the work that went into this and
creating something for you to tap into
that full potential to live into the
person you're meant to be so can we
commit to stay also can I just defend us
a little bit here yeah just
when when
the key marketing phrases are tap into
your full potential
put your name and your email into this
form yeah
how how am I not supposed to think
that's that's MLM yeah to a t yeah
you're gonna sign up for that and it's
like sell these protein powders to your
family yeah for twenty thousand dollars
to achieve your full potential Financial
Independence can we commit to going all
we use Tavernier full potential in our
like cult
ad yeah yeah yeah yeah
did we yes
like that that's very directly that's
what we're referencing yeah can you put
it in
[Applause]
it
it's so funny if they cut it's so funny
if they cut to the chat and it was just
like just nasty [__]
nasty and [__] like horny or like yeah
yeah like super horny oh lick me Matthew
I want to lick him I want to eat him up
can we go all in let's cut to the chat
right now let's commit to going oh man
you go all into anywhere oh I want to go
I want to go all in on his cocking balls
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
that dude's just sitting over there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm all in
I love McConaughey all in I'm all in all
in
Fallen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all in
I'm all inside me all right all right
all right yes yes
you know we know you're there for bro
you know he's just drunk as hell on the
zoom
you know Maddie he brings the ladies out
so you know
maybe I get lucky yeah I've been
starting private chats with every single
one of these girls in the chat hey Heidi
are you all in like me oh
are we all in right now
you me Heidi let's ride let's ride this
thing out all in where you from yo yeah
you tapping into your full potential
yeah I'm trying to tap into mine I'm
trying to find it
you know
people say I'm as sexy as Matthew
sometimes I'm not too sure what they
mean by that
where you from Heidi
cello thank you cello
thank you Dean
you know
oh
Dean dude the [__] triggering of the
of the cheering is crazy man after how
how Boomer is that yeah dude cheering
tracks sorry you hear the way it cut out
right there Liz lizard
you know
after
publishing ring you know
volume zero
I love it because like all of these
people like their favorite show is like
friends
you know what I mean and so they they
couldn't even understand the live aspect
yes yeah yeah like if it was just
Matthew in a room like a typical live
stream is they'd be like something's
missing yeah I don't understand this
yeah dude that [__] Gangland
silhouette right there yeah half these
people look like thumbs man look at that
[__] worm next to the silhouette dude
where is that guy he's underwater man I
was I was bombarded with the request to
go deeper into the approach and reveal
some process
and that serendipitously is when Tony
and Dean called saying hey hey
McConaughey we love your book we want to
go deeper and get even more practical
with it all right who else wants to go
deeper I'm all in go deeper with me with
you
bro I'm sorry
if okay I know when you're like talking
live like you get nervous energy out
but if his form of this is walking
forwards and backwards I'm gonna lose my
[__] mind man
uh press play damn it button's not
working now I said uh
yes and here we are
after eight months of creating this
project this one live right here right
now with you
we have all intentions today of
supplying what you demand
Dean and Tony I can't believe your
ability and desire to influence so many
people in such unanimously popping and
Tony
durability and desire to influence so
many people in such shoes unanimously is
truly inspiring uh and and the fact that
you're out to do more than just Inspire
bro I'm crying because he they gave you
like the quote custom Zoom background
and that's what all the red ones are oh
my God they're like yes thank you
Matthew
you know
yeah you're actually here with that
Matthew well yeah why does he talk he's
gonna finger your [__] because as you do
he knows what he's doing yeah now if he
was doing this that's like all right
yeah yeah come on yeah yeah
we're here to go deep deeper yeah deeper
you know
get some get some water flowing
make it cry a little bit
Amen to that thank you for giving me
that call so thank you Dean thank you
Tony also Marie Trent Carissa and so
many other talented folks
for choosing to make the time and do
such specific and high-end work that we
finally get to share with you
today
yeah
all right now
dude what is with these kiss cam
graphics
thank you
all of you
oh two million of you he's gonna cry
you got a choice
you ain't got to be here
they'll be doing whatever you do every
other Monday or any other time but
you're not you're here I gotta I'm
enthralled you made the time yeah you
chose to take all of us sort of like you
showed up
he's [__] good at what he does yeah I
mean he almost just cried yeah for for
thanking people for joining a live
stream dude the years you didn't go you
think when he's getting ready like when
he's becoming Matthew McConaughey he's
like
I'm not the body this [__] yeah yeah for
sure like he's like
when I go to thank them yeah yeah what's
what like he's just telling his Asian
he's like Watch How I do watch what the
f watch what the [__] happened what the
[__] I'm about to do when I say thank
you I am him yeah